wir haben eine damen und herren mit
jetzt kommt der abgeordnete das sind
hochsauerlandkreis friedrich mehr als
vor einem jahr hat er die wahl gegen
annegret kramp karrenbauer verloren und
seine kritik aus den vergangenen tagen
war weniger eine kritik an der
vorsitzenden er will auch gar nicht
vorsitzender der cdu werden das hat er
jetzt schon in mehreren interviews
gesagt er will halt die kanzlerfrage
offen halten und ich bin gespannt wie
ihr das hier vor den delegierten
formulieren wird viele delegierte waren
zu mittag essen mittlerweile sind die
reihen wieder fest geschlossen denn
jetzt kommt der punkt auf den viele
gewartet haben er bat us-präsident liebe
annegret meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren unsere partei vorsitzende
annegret kramp karrenbauer hat dort
morgen eine kämpferische und eine mutige
und nach vorn zeigende rede gehalten und
dafür sind wir alle wirklich richtig
dankbar
da haben auch kritische töne nicht
gefehlt und ich habe auch vor drei
wochen das erscheinungsbild der
bundesregierung scharf kritisiert
ich habe dafür viel zustimmung bekommen
aber auch manches an kritik die kritik
die mich am meisten nicht nur erreicht
sondern auch tropfen hat war
jetzt werdet ihr wie die spd
meine damen und herren liebe
parteifreunde
wir werden nicht wie die spd
wir dürfen auch nicht wie die spd werden
die spd wählt die spd welt in der
nächsten woche ihren neuen ehemaligen
parteivorsitzenden
der einzige unterschied ist in der
langen ahnengalerie der vorsitzenden
kommt nicht ein bild sondern zwei alles
andere wird bei dieser partei so weiter
gehen sie wählen und am montag drauf
geht die kritik am neu gewählten
vorsitzenden und seiner co-vorsitzenden
wieder los das ist der unterschied
zwischen uns und den sozialdemokraten
die sozialdemokraten sind strukturell
jacken und wir sind loyal zu unserer
vorsitzenden unserer parteiführung
und
und zur bundesregierung die wir seit
über 50 jahren tragen und das waren gute
jahre für deutschland
wir haben hier in leipzig im jahr 2003
und darauf ist hingewiesen worden
schon mal ein parteitag gab ja wir waren
in der opposition und haben ein mutiges
programm entwickelt ich habe damals auch
hier gestanden und besprochen und mir
ist während meiner rede das beispiel mit
dem bierdeckel eingefallen
das begleitet mich jetzt seit 16 jahren
es gibt schlimmere schicksale als von
einem bierdeckel begleitet zu werden
aber ich stelle mir die frage warum ist
eigentlich dieser bierdeckel immer noch
so populär
ich habe eine vermutung nicht die
assoziation die viele von ihnen
vielleicht haben sondern ich habe eine
vermutung
ich vermute dass die menschen die das
gut fanden gesagt haben
da bringt mal jemand auf einen einfachen
verständlichen nenner was wir in einer
komplexen welt politisch wollen
es war das symbol für etwas
verständlicher für etwas einfaches
und wenn wir wenn wir heute feststellen
liebe freundin freude das vertrauen
schwindet in die institutionen und in
die politischen parteien und diese
umfrage der letzten woche ist hier ja
schon 23 mal zitiert worden
dann ist meine antwort wir müssen wieder
die fähigkeit besitzen zu erklären nicht
zu simplifizieren aber auf einen
einfachen verständlichen nenner zu
bringen wo wir heute stehen wo wir hin
wollen und wie der weg dorthin geht
einfach und verständlich
in einer komplexer und schwieriger
werdenden welt und ich sehe aus meiner
sicht zwei große themen die uns dazu
geradezu einladen und verpflichten aus
christlich demokratische union
das erste ist das thema außen und
sicherheitspolitik diese welt wird
risikoreicher schwieriger komplexer die
nato steht auf dem prüfstand
und ich will auch an dieser stelle an
noch einmal sagen ich bin unserer
parteivorsitzenden in ihrer eigenschaft
als verteidigungsministerin
ausgesprochen dankbar dass sie den mut
gehabt hat erste vorschläge zu machen
wie deutschland diese neue verantwortung
in zukunft wahrnehmen will
das waren erste schritte aber die haben
gezeigt dass wir wieder mut haben können
solche entscheidungen zu treffen
[Applaus]
welche rolle will deutschland spielen
welche verantwortung sind wir bereits zu
übernehmen welche führungsverantwortung
ist deutschland bereit zu übernehmen in
der außen und sicherheitspolitik
aber auch in der wirtschafts und
finanzpolitik und diese wirtschafts und
finanzpolitik steht vermutlich in den
nächsten jahren wenn nicht jahrzehnten
vor einer großen vielleicht sogar vor
ihrer größten bewährungsprobe
liebe freundinnen freunde täuschen wir
uns doch bitte nicht
greenpeace kann das ding da das c
abmontieren
das können die behalten und sollen die
mit nach hause nehmen und sich ins
wohnzimmer stellen da wird das
segensreiche wirkung entfalten aber das
aber das liebe freundinnen freunde das
was dahinter steht das was dahinter
steht das nehmen sie uns nicht dass wir
nämlich auch wirtschafts und
finanzpolitik aus einem wertefundament
heraus formulieren und gerade vor dem
hintergrund dieser geradezu dramatischen
entwicklung auf der welt und bitte
leugnet keiner dass wir ein problem
haben wir haben ein sehr sehr
ernsthaftes problem
über die ursachen und kausalitäten kann
man reden aber wir haben ein problem
und dieses problem müssen wir mit der
marktwirtschaft lösen und nicht ohne
oder gar gegen sie und das wird die
größte aufgabe sein
vor dir wir möglicherweise
stehen werden
und das ist die entscheidende
auseinandersetzung die wir dann auch mit
den grünen suchen müssen
liebe freundinnen freunde natürlich sind
da viele unterwegs die am liebsten
dieses vehikel nehmen würden um gleich
die ganze wirtschaftsordnung
abzuschaffen und die stimmen derer die
das wollen werden ja laut und lauter
wir wollen das nicht wir wollen mit
dieser marktwirtschaftlichen ordnung
diese herausforderung bestehen
aber das wird schwierig das erfordert
mut zur veränderung und mut kommt von
etwas zumuten
wir werden der bevölkerung etwas zumuten
müssen wir müssen führen in dieser
schwierigen politischen zeit das geht
auch nicht ohne oder gar gegen europa
das geht nur mit europa und in der
europäischen union und das geht wie die
csu es das geht wie die csu wie ich
finde richtiger weise sagt das geht
nicht gegen die bevölkerung sondern das
geht nur mit der bevölkerung
die menschen sitzen nicht da und machen
sich von morgens bis abends gedanken
darüber ob nun tatsächlich oder
vermeintlich die welt endet die machen
sich gedanken darüber wie der monat
endet für sie und ihre familien stadt
nicht von mir dieses zitat sondern aus
einem buch bin zwar die promovierte aber
ich sage die kühe trotzdem von jan
werner müller der gesagt hat furcht oder
freiheit furcht oder freiheit ist die
frage vor der wir stehen
und das unterscheidet uns
und das liebe freundinnen und freunde
unterscheidet uns auch von den grünen
ja es ist eine wunderbare sache dass
sich da viele junge menschen wieder für
politik engagieren und greta tun welche
seine beeindruckende person aber wenn
sie sagt dass wir ihr die jugend geraubt
hätten
da muss man hier sagen nein ihr habt in
der generation die beste jugend gehabt
die es jemals überhaupt in diesem teil
der welt jemals überhaupt in diesem teil
der welt gegeben hat
aber wenn das so bleiben soll dass diese
junge generation auch in der nächsten
und in der übernächsten generation
solche chancen hat dann müssen wir heute
viel ändern damit es morgen so bleibt
und das ist die eigentliche
herausforderung vor der wir stehen
wir sind da in einem prozess von diesem
parteitag wird jetzt auch in den medien
relativ viel erwartet nein nicht dieser
parteitag wird die endgültigen
entscheidungen treffen sondern in einem
jahr nach einem weiteren prozess des
nachdenkens des entscheidens des
vorbereitungs auf diesem parteitag dann
im jahr 2020 der diese entscheidenden
antworten geben muss wir sind am anfang
dieses prozesses und ganz gewiss nicht
am ende
wir müssen diesen prozess mit
glaubwürdigen personen verbinden danke
für die hinweise die von ihren sparen
von annegret kramp karrenbauer kamen und
wir müssen uns in dieser breite der
partei aufstellen verantwortung
übernehmen und führung zu zeigen und die
wir vorher nie erlauben sie mir dass ich
ein ganz offenes wort auch sage zu
unserer partei wir können draußen nicht
über den zusammenhalt der gesellschaft
sprechen wenn wir in der partei den
einen oder anderen oder gar ganze
gruppen ausgrenzen
um es noch deutlicher zu sagen
solange sie auf dem boden unseres
grundsatzprogramms stehen haben sowohl
die werte union als auch die union der
mitte ihren platz in der union und das
aller beste wäre wenn es solche gruppen
gar nicht geben müsste dass sie nämlich
alle in der mitte der union sind und mit
arbeiten an den themen die wir für
wichtig halten und die wir erarbeiten
meine damen und herren liebe
parteifreunde wir haben schwierige
zeiten aber wir müssen doch an die
erzählung des kulturpessimismus und des
niedergangs eine andere erzählung setzen
nämlich eine erzählung der zuversicht
und des optimismus und des
selbstvertrauens dass wir die probleme
unserer zeit lösen können
und zu dieser lösung gehört dass wir
nicht gegen technologie sondern mit
technologie diese lösung suchen nicht
gegen die moderne sondern mit der
moderne
diese wege aufzeigen und diese wege
suchen und dann und dann liebe
freundinnen freunde will ich auch ganz
ehrlich noch zu mir etwas sagen ich habe
das bei der jungen union gesagt und
wiederhole dass hier heute ich hab da
gesagt wenn sie wollen dass ich dabei
bin dann bin ich dabei wiederholt dass
heute hier aber mit beiden teilen dieses
satzes
und das geht nicht um mich oder gar noch
um irgendwelche niederen motiven die mir
dabei unterstellt werden es geht darum
dass diese christlich demokratische
union die eine so große verantwortung
für dieses land und für die europäische
union hat dass diese christlich
demokratische union zusammen mit der csu
auch bereit und in der lage ist ihre
verantwortung für deutschland in den
nächsten jahren vielleicht jahrzehnten
so erfolgreich zu führen und
wahrzunehmen wie wir das in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten gemacht haben
darum geht es dass wir zusammen das
machen dafür stehe ich hier dass wir
gemeinsam diesen erfolg für deutschland
und für europa haben und ich finde dafür
lässt sich kämpfen streiten dann müssen
wir auch mal aushalten dass wir
unterschiedliche meinungen haben aber
nie zurück gerichtet immer nach vorne
ausgerichtet und mit dem klaren willen
verantwortung in führung für dieses land
so zu übernehmen dass die menschen uns
vertrauen dass da nicht rechts und links
alles stärker wird sondern dass die
mitte wieder stärker wird und dass die
menschen sagen ja die führen spannende
manchmal auch kontroversen diskussionen
in ihren reihen aber alle zusammen ein
dass sie diese verantwortung für
deutschland wahrnehmen wollen und die
menschen trauen uns das dann auch zu und
diese botschaft muss von leipzig sowie
schon einmal 2003 auch im jahr 2009 10
ausgehen und dafür stehe ich hier und
dafür möchte ich mit ihnen zusammen
kämpfen herzlich
dank
sehr viel applaus für friedrich merz hat
ja eine programmatische rede gehalten
hat sich vor der vorsitzende nach ihrer
durchschlagenden redeverbot das kann man
nicht anders sagen greenberg angegriffen
und aber auch gleichzeitig seine
position verdeutlicht dass er mitspielen
möchte wie auch immer das aussehen soll
aber auch das hat er nicht gesagt bei
der kanzlerfrage möchte ein wort
mitreden nationen